THE SHOW THAT’S THE SWORN ENEMY
OF LYING, POMPOSITY, SMUGNESS
AND GROUPTHINK.
AND, IT’S A GREAT SEAN HANNITY.
>> Hannity: WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
TONIGHT WE ARE TRACKING MULTIPLE
MAJOR BREAKING STORIES INCLUDING
HISTORY OF MADE OF THE HOUSE FOR
THE GROUNDBREAKING PEACE ACCORD
BETWEEN ISRAEL, THE UAE AND
BAHRAIN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CALLING AT
THE DAWN OF A NEW MIDDLE EAST,
MEDIA MOB DEMOCRATS PREDICTABLY
AND NOTICEABLY UPSET, APPARENTLY
THEIR HATRED OF ALL THINGS TRUMP
IS CLEARLY MORE IMPORTANT THAN
WORLD PEACE ESPECIALLY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND WE WILL EXPLAIN
ALL THIS COMING UP TONIGHT.
PLUS HANNITY 2020 ELECTION
CORRESPONDENCE, OUR OWN LAWRENCE
LAWRENCE JONES ON THE GROUND IN
FRONT OF A BITE AN EVENT WHERE
SUPPORTER IS TURNED OUT IN FULL
FORCE TO GIVE JOE A WARM
WELCOME.
YESTERDAY IN A TRULY UNHINGED
SPEECH, BIDEN PREDICTED THAT
MAN-MADE CLIMATE CHANGE ON
FOSSIL FUELS THAT HE WILL
ELIMINATE WILL SOON DESTROY THE
WORLD.
TODAY HE BOARDED A MASSIVE
PRIVATE JET, OF COURSE.
LOTS OF CARBON EMISSIONS, AND IN
THE RULES ONLY APPLY TO WE THE
PEOPLE, YOU, NOT.
BUT HEY, MAYBE WE SHOULD GIVE
JOE THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT AND
MAYBE, MAYBE HE FORGOT ALL ABOUT
YESTERDAY’S INSANE CLIMATE
CHANGE SPEECH.
OBVIOUSLY HAVING COGNITIVE
ISSUES, AND THAT’S BEING POLITE.
AFTER ALL HE’S HAVING MORE AND
MORE TROUBLE RECALLING BASIC
FACTS, BUT THEY HAVE THE WEEK IT
IS, WHAT OFFICE HE’S RUNNING FOR
AND WHETHER HE IS CALLING FOR
ELECTION OR REELECTION.
HIS RUNNING MATE BY THE WAY,
KAMALA HARRIS, I THINK IT IS THE
HARRIS-BIDEN TICKET NOW.
>> HE SENDS IT DAILY TROOP
UPDATES.
U.S. TROOPS DIED IN IRAN AND
AFGHANISTAN.
THE HARRIS-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WILL RELAUNCH THAT EFFORT.
IF YOU WERE A QUARTERMASTER, YOU
COULD SURELY TAKE CARE OF
RUNNING A DEPARTMENT STORE, YOU
KNOW, IN THE SECOND FLOOR OF THE
LADIES DEPARTMENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> Hannity: NO, I DON’T KNOW
WHAT YOU MEAN.
IN CASE YOU’RE KEEPING TRACK JOE
MIXED UP IRAN AND IRAQ.
HE WENT ON A BIZARRE RANT ABOUT
QUARTERMASTER’S AND DEPARTMENT
SHOW STORIES AND EVEN THOUGH HIS
RUNNING MATE IS ALREADY PLOTTING
HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> I HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
TOGETHER WITH JOE BIDEN AS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
WILL BITE ACCESS TO $100 BILLION
IN LOW-INTEREST LOANS.
>> Hannity: SO JUST 49 DAYS
BEFORE YOU BECOME THE ULTIMATE
JURY, AND ELECTION DAY.
WOULD YOU HIRE JOE TO MANAGE AND
RUN EVEN A BUSY McDONALD’S
RESTAURANT?
THAT’S A HARD JOB.
LOTS OF ORDERS AND YOU HAVE TO
RACE AROUND.
LET ME SEE, FRENCH FRIES, AND A
QUARTER POUNDER, LET ME GO BACK
AND LOOK.
WHAT WAS IT AGAIN, QUARTER
POUNDER WITH CHEESE.
I DON’T KNOW, BIDEN CAN BARELY
LEAVE HIS BASEMENT WITHOUT
HAVING A FULL ON PUBLIC
MELTDOWN.
CONSTANTLY REFUSING TO TAKE
QUESTIONS FROM EVEN HIS ADORING
FANS ON THE MEDIA MOB AND ALL OF
THESE EVENTS THAT HE DOES ARE
ALL SCRIPTED COMPLETE WITH HIS
TRUSTY TELEPROMPTER.
IN AN INTERVIEW TODAY BIDEN’S
CAMPAIGN MANAGER SEEMLY
CONFIRMING HER CANDIDATES
DEPENDENT ON THE TELEPROMPTER
BUT HE ALSO LIED AND SAID HE
TAKES QUESTIONS FROM REPORTERS
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
NO, THAT’S A LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THESE
INTETERVIEWS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD SAY
VERY CLEARLY WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT USES THE
TELEPROMPTER, BUT HE IS ALSO OUT
THERE EVERY DAY TAKING QUESTIONS
FROM REPORTERS.
>> Hannity: KNOW HE’S NOT.
IN TRUTH AND REALITY, JOE BIDEN
DOESN’T TAKE QUESTIONS FROM
REPORTERS BECAUSE HE DOESN’T
SEEM TOO CAPABLE OF SPEAKING
FREELY WITHOUT SAYING, MOVE IT
UP -- MOVE IT UP, YEAH.
YEAH.
TWO WEEKS FROM TONIGHT, AND IN
49 DAYS YOU WILL DECIDE THE FATE
OF THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
I CANNOT COMFORTABLY PREDICT
WHAT WILL HAPPEN AND NO ONE ELSE
CAN EITHER.
BUT LET ME PUT IT LIKE THIS.
2 MINUTES LEFT IN THE GAME,
FOURTH QUARTER, NO TIMEOUTS AND
IT’S A TWO MINUTE DRILL.
YOU NEED TO MARCH DOWN THE FIELD
80 YARDS AND CROSS THE PLANE,
AND THE EXTRA POINT TO WIN.
IT WON’T BE EASY, AND NEVER IS.
IF YOU CARE ENOUGH ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY, AND THAT’S A PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH AND NOT
APPEASEMENT.
AND A LOT ON THE BALLOT IN 49